guys today we are going to create a
social network using flask and Python by
the end of this video you will know how
to create a full stack social network
including a database server and your
front-end and yeah let's get right to it
thanks for watching
so first thing that you want to do is
create your directory for your project
so we're gonna call the directory net so
let's go ahead and create that now we're
gonna say open up a terminal or command
prompt and say mkdir net okay then we
want to go ahead and change into that
net and it's going to be an empty folder
at this point now what we want to do is
say pip install so assuming you have
Python installed on your computer you're
going to have pip which is the Python
package manager we're gonna say pip
install virtual env okay so virtual env
is a package that will allow us to
create an environment where we can keep
the specific versions of the Python
packages that we are using for this
project separate from our from the
Python that is installed on our computer
okay we are doing this so we can keep
track of those packages and then if
anyone wants to reproduce our project
they know exactly what packages they
need to install so once we have
virtually env installed on our computer
we're gonna say source oh no actually we
were gonna say virtual env and then we
want to say the name of the Python
version that we're going to use so we're
gonna say - - Python equals Python 3.6
and then we want to specify the name of
our directory so we're gonna say my env
okay so now that's going to create that
virtual environment for us again this is
where all our PI Python packages that we
install are going to be saved - once we
activate that so the way we do that
again we're still in the same directory
we say source my VNV bin activate
Oh once that guy's oh my env there we go
bin and activate okay so now we are
inside of our virtual environment now we
can install our packages so we are going
to need one package in particular for
this which is flask so flask is a is it
Python web framework that makes it very
easy to get a website up and running
quickly it allows us to create a basic
server as well as render HTML to the
page when our user comes to visit it ok
so let's go ahead here and say pip
install flask so after our virtual
environment has been activated that
doesn't want to take that package and
bring it into our virtual environment
for us to use so now let's go ahead here
and now we want to create our database
schema okay so now we're gonna dive into
we have our dev environment setup we're
gonna dive into how to create the
application itself so the first step in
doing this is creating in the database
schema so in our case we are only going
to have one table okay and a table and a
database is where you store all
information okay
generally you may have multiple tables
in our case we're just gonna have one
which is posts so let's go ahead and
create a file we're gonna call it schema
SQL okay
so this is where we are going to create
the or specify the values that are going
to be in our database table okay so
we're gonna say in this case here let's
go ahead let me open it up here okay so
we're gonna say drop table if exists
posts all right and then we want to say
create table posts so what this is doing
is this is saying if that table exists
already in the database go ahead and
drop it and then create a new one with
the things that we are going to specify
in just a minute here now these things
we're going to specify our unique values
in our database so first thing we want
to do is create a unique identifier for
every post so we want to say ID which is
going to be the name of our of our
column in our database table where that
value is going to go so every database
table has columns that make up the
values that really
to those entries into the database okay
so we want to say ID integer and that is
going to be the primary key and that is
going to auto increment so this is a
little bit of lingo here guys this is
just sing sequel syntax for creating a
primary key that auto increments so what
that means is this is the the integer
that is going to represent or reference
the each individual post and as each
post is added into our database you can
think of it as you define the column
values and then each post you add is a
new row in your table and that is going
to be a new entry into your database
that corresponds with those column
values at the top so we have ID integer
as a primary key and that's going to
auto increment so that means for each
new entry into our database that is
going to increase by one so now we want
to create a name so we're gonna say name
is going to be text that means is a text
value and it's going to be not null so
this is going to be for our entries so
now we're thinking for each post that
comes into our social network we want to
be able to create this we want to be
able to post an entry into our database
right and in this case we want to know
the name of the person that created it
and we want to have the content of the
post and that's what's going to be put
into our database so that is the first
value name is text not null next up here
we want to grab the content so we're
gonna say content text not know so what
not null is doing is that saying if they
if we try to create an entry and that is
a content or name is not specified
return an error because we want name and
content to be specified for every single
entry in our database okay so now that
we've got that let's go ahead and just
add our closing parenthesis closing
semicolon and right and quit this
alright so now we have our schema now
we're going to use our schema SQL in
order to generate our database file so
let's go ahead here and use sequel Lite
three this is a very light version of a
database you might have heard of called
my sequel and this come built-in with
Python so we're gonna say sequel Lite 3
and then we want to put database dB
specifying the name of the database file
it can be anything dot DB
and then we're gonna put a little less
than sign and then we want to put the
schema SQL after that okay and by the
way guys if you haven't used
autocomplete before in the terminal when
you start typing the name of a file and
click tab it will go ahead and it will
create the rest of that file name for
you so again that's what I'm doing there
to quickly generate that so we say
sequel 8-3 database DB less than sign
schema SQL and click enter so now when
we click LS to see the files here we see
that there is a database DB file alright
so now we have we created our schema we
created our database now we need to
create the server which is going to
handle the interactions with the
database so to give you guys just a
general overview of what the structure
of a full-stack application looks like
you have your front end which is the
view ok when you come to any website you
see on the internet you are seeing the
front end of a website that is the view
and the information that is being
displayed on that most often comes from
a database so what is going on in
between there that would be the server
so we have the view and the server
receives requests for information from
the user which comes from the view right
so the user comes to the view from there
they're able to make certain requests to
the server for information they want to
see then the server goes grabs that
information out of the database pulls it
back and then sends it to the user which
is viewing everything so you can think
of it in three parts we have the view we
have the server and we have the database
right and the server is going to
interact is going to be the intermediary
in between they're pulling information
from the database making the changes
that we want to make before we send it
back to the to the user who is viewing
it and then sends that information back
to the front-end to where the user is
viewing it ok so right now we've created
that final part that's the that's the
database so now let's go ahead here and
create that intermediary part which is
going to be the server so let's go ahead
here and say we're going to open up the
server and that is going to be app dot
py ok so now what we're doing here is
we're going
and we are opening up this file here
this is going to be our server file ok
and generally speaking you can name that
app py that is sort of a good practice
okay so let's go ahead here now and
install the packages actually let's go
getting a little ahead of ourselves here
so let's install the packages so we're
gonna say pip install pip install flask
right so that will
oh we already installed that okay so
that's gonna bring down that package for
us that's again how we're gonna make our
web framework I'm gonna move over out of
the terminal for you guys and we're
gonna open up and grab net okay so this
is this is our file right here and again
we have our app dot py file which is
going to be where we are going to add
the information for our server ok so the
first thing that we were going to do
here is we're going to import flask so
we want to say from flask import flask
I'm go ahead move myself down here
import flask render template this is
going to be for displaying the HTML that
we want to display on the screen then
we're gonna say also let's see what else
do we need here flask render template
all we need requests in order to grab
the information that is going to be the
content and the name of the user off the
request that's coming in and then we see
let's see here
flask render template requests what else
are we going to need we are going to
need up about redirect no I think we're
good I think that might be enough okay
so now we want to go here go ahead here
and we're gonna say we want to create
our actual server object so we're gonna
say app equals flask and then we go
ahead and we pass name as the parameter
here okay so that is going to create our
server object and it's called app so now
that we have that we want to create the
routes okay so when you have a server
you have different routes that you can
hit these are known as endpoints routes
basically synonymous but essentially
what they do are they are unique
endpoints which tell the server which
the
server uses to decide what data to send
back to the to the view half write to
the user the view part of our full stack
application so in this case say we
wanted to login a user we would often
hit an endpoint called something like
login and then that would run the
necessary code on the server looking for
the necessary information that was sent
to the server in order to login the user
so in our case here we just want to be
able to see a home page and then be able
to create posts and see the posts that
have been created so let's go ahead here
and let's say app app dot route and
we're just going to do a back slash so
this is just going to be the very home
page of our application once we start it
up which we will do here in just a
second so we're gonna say app app dot
route with just the back slash this
could be anything like back slash home
back slash login back slash whatever you
guys want to put you can specify
whatever name that's just gonna be your
endpoint you have to send the request to
in order to receive that response back
from the server so now we're gonna say
we want to say methods right so when you
are sending information whether you're
sending information or any kind of
information on the internet we use
things called methods so in this case
the methods are going to be or include
post put delete and there's a few other
ones as well get is obviously the most
common one so when you make a request to
see any webpage on the Internet
that's a get request you're saying I
want to get this information and they
send it back generally that is going to
be the web page the initial web page ok
beside that we have post which is saying
here's some information store in the
database put which is saying here's some
information you probably already have
this in the database update what you
have okay and then finally delete is
here's some information about what we
want you to remove from your database ok
now all of these methods these put posts
delete and get these are all known as
this is what's known as crud but as
another
acronym you may have heard of but
essentially these are again how you send
the data from the from the front end and
these are all user actions so these all
these are just acronyms for user actions
okay so let's go ahead here and say
there's two methods that are allowed for
this endpoint that is just going to show
our page with the posts and be able to
take in information so we're gonna say
the methods are get in order to get the
page and post okay so when the post is
for submitting all right so now that
we've got our our apt out route here
we're gonna create a function that's
going to execute when we hit this
endpoint so we're gonna say Def index
we're just going to call this function
index and then we're gonna say then we
want to say if requests dot method
equals get then in this case we're just
gonna pass okay because if it's a get
request we're going to go ahead and
return the template that we want our
user to see right because they're
requesting to see the web page so we're
gonna say return render template and
we're gonna create this in just a second
but for now it's going to be called
index.html okay we're going to create
that HTML file that a user will see when
they send an initial get request to our
server in just a second here so if
requests stop method equals get we want
to pass now otherwise here
if requests dot method equals post then
we want to go ahead here and we want to
grab the content so if it's a post
request we are making the assumption
that our user has already come to our
page and they are now posting
information to our web page via some
input fields that they see on their end
okay so we want to say request dot form
dot get and we're gonna name our inputs
in just a second but we're gonna call
them name and we're gonna say request
dot form get and then we're gonna call
the other one name and we'll say post
okay just for this is going to be the
value of whatever our user is the actual
information the the text that our users
posting
this is different from this post okay
this is the method itself and then this
is just a variable that's going to be
part of that data that we receive that
is going to contain the text okay so
we're gonna have a name name equals that
and post equals this and then we're
gonna go ahead here and now we are going
to create that post and store it in our
database okay so we're gonna call a
method called create post and we're
gonna pass in name and post okay so now
let's go ahead here and actually create
the file that's going to interact with
our database okay so we need we created
our database and right now we're
starting to create our server which is
going to handle requests but now we need
a way for our server to interact with
our database and we're gonna create a
thin layer that all functions that our
server is going to use to add things to
the database or remove things from the
database okay
so let's go ahead here and create that
file now and we're gonna call that file
models dot py okay so in here this file
we're going to say import SQL Lite 3 ok
and then we're going to go ahead here
and do some do some path up some pathing
so essentially guys when we get to this
when we get to this file here when we
get to this file here this is going to
be the thin layer that is going to
contain that information that is going
to allow our server to interact with the
database here and in this case we want
to directly know where our database file
is so we can open that up and interact
with that so we're gonna say root equals
path dot durn name and we're gonna say
path dot rel path file so again
essentially this is saying get the
directory name and then get the direct
path to whatever file we pass in as the
file for this okay so we're gonna say so
we're gonna use that in just a second
you guys we'll see how that ties in
nicely but we're gonna go ahead here now
and say I'll create a function that's
going to create a post ok so when that
request comes in it's going to call this
function with those with the with the
and the post data from that request and
then it's going to insert that into the
database so let's go ahead and say def
create post and remember it's going to
receive two parameters that is name and
content okay and now we want to go ahead
and create a connection to our database
so we're going to say conte equals SQL
connect and then we want to say path dot
join root and then the name of our
database file so database dot DB okay so
now we've made a connection to our
database now we're going to define a a
thing called a cursor so essentially
guys in order to efficiently pull data
or not not pull data but traverse the
database and find the information that
we need we're going to use a thing
called cursor and what the cursor does
is instead of grabbing the whole
database it just goes to what we need
and makes it much more efficient for us
okay so we're gonna say cur equals con
dot cursor okay so that's going to say
this is the this is the the variable
that represents the instrument or object
that is going to move over our database
and find the information we need so now
we're gonna say cur dot execute so this
is going to execute raw sequel syntax
for inserting a post into the database
so we're gonna say insert into posts
which is our table name and content so
insert into the name and content columns
you know let's roll back insert a row
into the name and content columns that
is going to contain this data that was
passed as a parameter okay
so we're gonna say insert into name
content values question mark question
mark and then we want to go ahead here
and fill in those values what those are
gonna be so in this case that is going
to be name and content alright so that
will execute that sequel statement after
making a connection to our database
inserting in the name of the person who
posted and the content of the post next
up here we're going to say
Khanh not commit and con not close so
that's going to commit that entry to the
database finalizing it kind of writing
it in stone and then close the
connection to the database now we want
to create one more method in this file
as well which is get posts so you want
to say def get posts and that's going to
be that's actually not going to take any
parameters that's just gonna pull all
the posts that we want out of the
database so we can display them on the
HTML template that we allow our user to
see so we're gonna say def get posts and
we're gonna say con equals SQL connect
path dot join route and database DB just
like above there and then we say cur
equals con cursor and then we want to
execute a little bit different sequel
this time so we're gonna say curda
execute select all which is represented
by this little star all from posts which
is the name of our table so that's going
to pull all the entries out of our table
and then we want to go ahead here and
say posts equals curt fetch all so that
will go ahead and store all those
entries into our database that we pulled
out with that last sequel statement and
store them in the post variable then we
want to go ahead and return posts okay
alright so that will go ahead and do
that that will grab all our posts for us
so now we have that file we're able to
interact now with our database with that
thin layer we have our database written
written and now we want to finish out
our server here so let's go ahead and
check this out here and now we're gonna
go ahead here and create a few final
elements okay so this is going to be we
have our create post and now we want to
go ahead here and just say posts equals
get posts right so that is going to go
ahead and grab all of the posts using
that method we just created in our
models dot py file here grab all the
posts
the database and return them so that we
can display them on the screen so we
have post equals get post and then we
want to go ahead and return well we have
our render template right there and then
we're going to pass a another parameter
and we're going to call it posts equals
posts so what this is doing here when we
create our template which is what our
user is going to see initially and then
every time they submit a post we
rerender that template updating it to
reflect any new posts so in this case we
are creating a variable called posts and
we are passing in posts so when that
template wants to access what those
posts are it can do so by referencing
this variable that we are passing in to
it right here you can think of that more
or less as a variable okay so we've got
that yes so that looks pretty good that
should be just about everything that we
need here Oh something else that we do
want to do here is say from flask Coors
import Coors okay so this is not always
necessary but this these are security
precautions that are going to allow our
server to run properly here so
essentially we're going to install this
package in just a minute but these are
just security precautions to prevent
certain things like cross-site scripting
which could say essentially that
influences our sequel could pretend well
okay there's a couple different things
that can happen there
one we could someone could inject new
sequel code into our application to see
every all the contents of our database
and we don't want that to happen so that
can help do stings again
protect against that and also cross-site
scripting in this case we're not using
any JavaScript specifically so they
can't like insert JavaScript into our
code and kind of cheat it in but there's
other ways that you can cheat in other
code and essentially execute certain
things when users are trying to do
something else and generally those
certain things would be devious things
so we're going to go ahead and close and
close this out now okay all right so
that's what we've got now guys let's
check out oh yeah we don't need to close
it actually so let's check out what
we've got we've got our server we have
our models py file which is the thin
layer on top of the database to interact
with the database we have our database
file and then we have our schema and we
wrote to generate our database okay so
now the final thing we have to do is
create the HTML template that users are
going to see when they initially come to
the web site okay so let's go ahead and
now and create that okay so let's go
ahead and create that now so this file
is going to be well first we're gonna
store it in the directory flask always
looks in a directory called templates
for your templates to display to the
user so we're going to create directory
called templates in order to allow flash
to find that and then inside this
directory we're gonna create a file
called index.html okay now what this is
going to do here is we are going to be
able to display this to the user and the
user is then going to be able to see
this HTML and this is where we're going
to show the posts and allow the user to
submit new posts so we're going to say
doctype doctype is HTML and then we want
to say HTML and then we want to put the
body of our text so again guys these are
just regular old HTML tags here and in
the body here we're going to create a
form and we're just safe we're gonna say
form and then action equals backslash
here in between quotes that means it
will send whatever method we specify
after we submit this form to that end
point in that case that is this endpoint
right here and now we want to say what
request so in this case guys we defined
it so that if it's a post method then we
go ahead and we create these pull this
information and then we create the post
right we want that to happen so we're
gonna say method equals post and then we
want to go ahead here and put that
information in our form okay so let's go
ahead and say in here let's put
input with a placeholder to let the user
know what to put in there and that's
going to be named and then we're going
to say after that we're gonna go ahead
here and say name equals pod name
okay so this name field is going to
specify what the name what so right here
remember we're looking for name request
that formed it got that get name these
values right here that we're pulling are
specified in our form by this name field
right here okay
so we've got that input now we want to
create another input and this input is
going to be the content of the post so
we're gonna say placeholder input
placeholder equals equals uh well post
content and then we're gonna say name
equals post okay
now finally we have a final input which
is going to be our submit button so
we're gonna say input type equals submit
value equals submit all right and then
that will complete our form so right
here this is the form that is going to
be able to submit new posts to our
application now we are going to go ahead
here and create our now we want to
create our way to show the messages that
are in our posts right so remember we
are passing this right here post equals
post we want to be able to see all the
posts that are pulled out of the
database every time we render this
template right because we want to see an
updated view including all the posts
that have been recently submitted every
time that we see this template so let's
go ahead here and and do that now so
we're gonna say we're gonna say let's
see we're gonna first create some
special syntax here for for rendering
this Python right so this is why this is
a special template this is unique to
Python templating for HTML specific with
flask so we're gonna say for post in
posts so essentially we can write raw
Python in our HTML template and
to render things this is pretty cool
guys so check this out we say for post
in post and we want to return a div and
we're gonna say in that div we're just
gonna have a post post one plus a colon
and post to okay so remember in our
database field here in our schema we
have our ID we have our text and we have
our content okay
so in this case here when we get all
these posts out of the database it is
returning a set for us which is going to
have those three values so again the
first one will be the ID at zero index
second one will be the name of the first
index and third one will be the content
at the second index so we want to go
ahead and reference that in our
index.html file here with that and now
these two squiggly back is right here
just mean we are we are writing Python
okay so anytime you're doing like loops
or if statements you're going to go
ahead and use this and then anytime
you're rendering actual Python on to the
screen you're going to do that with
these two two consecutive squiggly
brackets with the information between
okay so now let's go ahead and close out
that div and now we can go ahead here
and we will need to end this for
statement so again this is specific to
flask and Python speaking Python
templating for HTML so we want to go
ahead and end that loop with the end for
here and now that should just about do
it for this here
so let's go ahead here and save this
template and now we know that we're
going to see that template when we when
we get this here because remember we
have return render template index.html
it looks inside the templates folder
finds that index.html pass in this posts
now in that index.html we have the form
for submitting new posts which when you
submit it sends a new post request to
this endpoint with that information
which is pulled off a new post is
created and then oops a new post is
created and then we have we grab all the
posts and return the template again and
then in that template we go ahead and we
loop over all those posts displaying the
name of the person who posted the
content of their post and then we end
that loop and then we end the that's the
end of that template okay so now in
order to get our server to run and have
anything up and going here we're gonna
say if name equals main app run and
we're gonna say debug equals true okay
so what this is doing is saying if this
is the file that is running so this if
not if name equals main ton syntax is
basically saying if this is fine if this
file is the actual file that was
selected to run then go ahead and
execute this otherwise it's just a
library then don't execute that whatever
is in that within that if statement
block okay so now we've got that app
that run deep vehicle's equals true so
let's go ahead here and now we're gonna
see what the errors are because I'm
assuming there's others errors that are
almost always errors so let's go ahead
here and see what we've got
so let's go ahead and activate our
virtual environment that has our Python
packages so we're gonna say source my
env bin activate virtual environment is
activated alright so now we are
referencing our our packages that we
specifically installed for this
application now we're gonna say pip
install flask cores alright so that will
grab that alright so you've got flask
ores now I don't think we need any other
packages I think those are the only two
we used yep okay so that looks good
there so now let's go ahead here and try
our running our server so python app dot
pi no module named flask
alright pip install flask okay so let's
try again Python app dot PI okay so it
looks like for some reason we are not
referring to our virtual environment
here when we try to install that package
let's try again here we'll say source my
env bin activate pip install flask let's
see here Python app top hi
okay um
we're gonna try this out we're gonna say
we're going to say source my envy bin
activate then we're going say which pip
okay so it looks like we're using PI of
the three point six we're gonna say hip
three install install flask and we're
gonna try Python three app dot pi okay
there we go so now our server is up and
running here let's go ahead and check
that out so we're going to go ahead and
put in one two seven looks like that
127.0.0.1 at four five thousand now we
are seeing that specified right here
oh it looks like we've have an error
okay so get posts get posts is not
defined okay so we need to import that
from our models file here let's go ahead
and say from models import create post
get posts try again
let me move myself out of the way and
let's see here invalid syntax import
sqlite3 it looks like we accidentally
remove that I that in their path is not
defined okay from OS import path try
again there we go okay so now we are up
and running here so now let's go ahead
here and check this out get post is not
defined again here so let's see what the
error is get post is not defined we have
our function right here we are importing
it get posts and then we are executing
it there hmm
get myself out of the way here see
something not saved correctly def get
post spelling is correct
hmm okay guys hang with me we are going
to figure so okay there we go so it
looks like something wasn't saved
correctly now we have named sequel is
not defined at SQL connect okay I was
wondering how I had so we're going to
say import sqlite3 as SQL I don't use
SQLite very often so that's my excuse
for not knowing that syntax okay so
let's go ahead here and say python 3 ab
dot pi there we go and now we can pull
this up here another error SQLite
connection object has no attribute Q ser
so we're going to go ahead and get rid
of that
that's what it should be all right ah we
don't need that okay now we'll try again
expect token and a print statement got
post okay so that is in our template so
we're getting very close here guys let's
go ahead to ah we need this other plus
right here oh boy
okay there we go and we try again there
we go okay so now we have our screen
here let's go ahead and put in an entry
and see what happens
so I'm going to say name equals John
post content is hello submit and again
we have a typo in our models file let's
go ahead and get rid of that alright and
we try again and there we go so John
says hello now we can go ahead and is
here and put John goodbye there we go
and our post shows up so now we'd go
ahead and close this out shut down our
whole application here and start it up
again
and we will see those posts are still
there because it is pulling from our
database file there we go there are
posts there's our name our content and
there we go
again thank you guys very much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
please give me a thumbs up would be
great
uh-huh please do subscribe if you guys
just got here and yeah thanks for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed have a
great night